vor zwei Wochen habe ich lustige
Schülerantworten Test part 8 hochgeladen
und
[Musik]
ja wir können alle rechnen und wissen
das jetzt Teil 9 kommt wir starten
direkt mit dieser Abbildung von einem
Läufer und der dazugehörigen Frage
welche Bewegung wird der Läufer aus
logischerweise läuft der Läufer halt
nach vorne weil man da 0 Sekunden 5
Sekunden 10 Sekunden sieht und der läuft
halt nach vorne läuft der Schüler
schreibt allerdings Yoga
begründe deine Antwort weil er still da
steht ja Bro das ist ein Zettel wie soll
man da eine Bewegung drauf darstellen
machen wir weiter mit dieser lustigen
schülerantwort und zwar steht dort schon
schreibe das heutige Datum und der
Schüler schreibt einfach das
heutige Datum
Bruder waren extra kleine Striche
der jetzt trotzdem hingeschrieben deine
Mutter kauft dir eine Jacke für 70 € und
eine Hose für 90 €, was ergibt das
schreibt mit Papa
ich darf den hatten wir schon mal oder
wenn ihr also auch Lust habt dann
schickt mir die auf Instagram
und das popsocket hier super um das
Handy zu halten
welche Probleme
entstehen durch Plastik im Meer
weniger Plastik an Land
ich meine
die Antwort ist nicht falsch aber es ist
halt kein Problem wie viele Buchstaben
haben die folgenden Worte und da stehen
die Worte Auge Name und Tag und dann
soll halt logischerweise die Buchstaben
zählen ist wahrscheinlich irgendwie 1
Klasse und man lernt gerade Mathematik
und Deutsch irgendwie zu verbinden die
Person schreibt allerdings bei Auge blau
mein Name schreibt die Person Paul
und bei Tag schreibt die Person heute
ich glaube da muss man einigen Fächer
noch mal an der Person arbeiten und the
sentence Mary eight all the cookies into
the passive use the Simple Past und die
Person schreibt wir Cookies
ja Arme Mary bei der nächsten lustigen
Schülerantworten geht es nicht um
irgendeine Antwort die auf eine
Fragestellung irgendwie ein bisschen
wird komisch lustig dumm war sondern
eine Person einfach ein Bären gezeichnet
Unternehmen geschrieben Krieg dieser
süße Bär ein extra Punkt ich Lehrerin
ich würde das geben ne
weil man muss ja auch solche Sachen
fördern so Kreativität und so ein Denken
outside of the Box welche Person auch
outside the box gedacht hat ist diese
hier denn die Frage ist was
unterscheidet den Saturn von den anderen
Planeten im Sonnensystem und
normalerweise schreibt man an dieser
komische Kreis darum rum ich weiß nicht
wie der genannt wird aber das ist der
Unterschied auch wird das Pluto einfach
nicht mehr mit drin ist ne
wird damals irgendwie so rausgekickt
weil er zu klein war
wie diskriminierend ist das gewesen für
den Pluto guck mir allerdings zurück zu
den lustigen Schülerantworten denn die
Person antwortet eigentlich wie
Mediamarkt nur orange
okay was ist die Konsequenz aus muss es
selbst nicht
und die Person auch nicht in der
schreibt einfach boah vergessen
[Gelächter]
bzw Fahrrad wenn es nicht weit ist
die Sache ist dass die Antworten halt
nicht dumm sind
die sind ja alle richtig natürlich kommt
er mit autofahrrad oder Bahn dahin außer
er hat jetzt vielleicht ein Privatjet
oder so wo allerdings wirklich meine
Lösung falsch ist ist hier denn da wird
nach dem richtigen langen Wort gefragt
also es ist wahrscheinlich auch eine
Aufgabe aus der zweiten Klasse oder so
lang Wort ist ja das heißt ja
ich habe keine Ahnung Version von einem
kurzen Wort also von der Abkürzung aber
ich weiß nicht was ist das Gegenteil von
der Abkürzung halt einfach dann Wort ne
na egal auf jeden Fall waren die Wörter
allgemein Kilometer pro Stunde und
trafometer oder irgendwie so Person
schreibt allerdings bei allgemein das
war doch richtig ein Kilometer pro
Stunde schreibt die Person an allerdings
Klo Meter
pro Stunde wahrscheinlich einfach ein
nie vergessen und bei Trafo schreibt die
Person Trends
und das ist definitiv falsch hier sollte
eine Person beantworten warum Napoleon
Bonaparte Kaiser wurde weil er es wollte
in welchem Alter möchtest du Kinder
bekommen nö
begründe deine Antwort weil die bestimmt
so werden wie ich und ich will mich
nicht so aufregen wie Papa jeden Tag das
ist tatsächlich eine sehr ehrliche
Antwort schreibt mal in die Kommentare
ob ihr Kinder bekommen möchtet und wenn
ja an welchem Alter
als ich zehn war nämlich das gefragt
wurde habe ich gesagt mit 25
ja
habt noch geiler in dieser Matte Klausur
gab es verschiedene Behauptungen und man
sollte ankreuzen ob die Aussage war oder
falsch ist die Person hat einfach alles
angekreuzt
ich meine
es ist richtig
also sie hat die richtigen Sachen
angekreuzt
aber halt auch die falschen
ich weiß auch noch dass bei uns damals
in einer Klausur dass man so war dass
wenn man gar nichts angekreuzt hat dann
logischerweise keine Punkte bekommen hat
aber wenn man das falsche angekreuzt hat
man sogar Punkte Abzug bekommen hat
damit wollten die Lehrer nämlich
verhindern dass man rät bei so fifty
fifty Sachen
das war ein Kranker gamech aber ich habe
davor immer nur geraten die nächste
lustige Schule Antwort kommt aus einer
Mathe Klausur und zwar war die Aufgabe
zeichnen die Funktion f mit der
Gleichung von x = 3 * - 3/4 X -
oder keine Ahnung in einem
Koordinatensystem ich habe selber keine
Ahnung
und die Person die die Antwort dort
geschrieben hat auch nicht an sie
schreibt einfach genau solche Aufgaben
habe ich nicht geübt weil ich gehofft
habe dass sowas heute nicht dran kommt
und das sind wahrscheinlich exakt die
Leute die das gesagt bekommen vom Lehrer
in der Stunde vor der Klausur und dann
nicht zuhören
ich weiß noch die Stunde vor der Klausur
war immer die schlimmste alle haben
Fragen gestellt ich dachte mir ich habe
eigentlich auch so viele Fragen aber
ich weiß nicht mal was ich fragen soll
so viele Fragen habe ich nenne die
passende Gleichung zum obigen
funktionsgrafen Telefonjoker
Wer wird Millionär
voll diskriminierend das ist Wer wird
Millionär heißt nicht Wer wird Millionär
in
Folge
ja das sieht doch nicht pleite sind ne
nenne das Präteritum von backen in der
dritten Person
Singular was ist Präteritum noch mal ich
schwöre wenn ich nicht wusste dass
Präteritum die Vergangenheitsform
im Deutschen ist ich glaube
gesagt dass es irgendwas aus dem
Biologieunterricht ist
oder Physik
euch nie wo kommt das Wort her nee
Präteritum
um Latein
ich habe da auch keine Ahnung Leute das
war's mit dem beschissensten Video Luca
will jetzt öfters Freunde oder Zuschauer
sein Intro beenden ich bin hier die
erste sendet ihm gerne alles auf
Instagram zu falls ihr auch mal in so
einer endcard oder wie auch immer das
heißt drin sein wollt ja abonnieren
liken Glocke aktivieren alle entscheiden